[Music]
first how are you doing today yeah under
an excellent before we get to start
talking I have to give a huge thank you
the only reason Collider gets to be at
Toronto and cover this fantastic Film
Festival is because of our sponsors I
want to give you a huge thank you to
Nordstrom Canada thank you for providing
this opportunity that's it that's all I
have and we're done okay right no um so
first of all a million things I want to
talk to you about so I'm gonna start
with the the first thing being when you
signed on to the boys did you have any
idea that that show was gonna explode
the way it did
interesting question not exactly but I
had a spidey sense when I was reading
these scripts I was I hadn't felt that
way about anything I'd read where I was
like there's something really special
going on here this is funny it's dark
it's it's complex there's like a total
allegory for the world we live in right
now so because of those reasons and then
the great vibes on set I was like kid
where there's some magic happening here
yes sure so I saw like everyone like I
watched episode one and I was not
prepared for things that were gonna
happen and when things I don't want to
spoil anything for the people that have
actually not seen it yet you should
really watch the boys it's [ __ ]
awesome sorry for the language but when
what happens to your character in that
first episode I was like what yeah I had
never I've seen a lot I've never seen
anything like that yeah so I think that
the way that they put they wrote the
scene the way they shot it it really was
a shock even when I I saw it at Tribeca
that's where it premiered and even I was
like oh my god right that happens right
there oh wow yeah Dan Trachtenberg did
the pilot man just curious what do you
remember about working with Dan because
you're setting in that first episode you
are setting up everything so it's like
you don't really know whatever you know
what I mean totally everything from
everything like that hone in the feel of
the show yeah so what was it like when
you were filming Dan was the best
honestly I had chemistry
I had a chemistry read with Jack which
Quade and it was just me Jack and Dan in
a room together and Dan the whole time
was like just ad-lib forget the lines
just have fun like in and so me and Jack
were probably in that room for like an
hour just messing around it was it was
the best and then on set he still set
the same precedent where it was like you
know just crack jokes it's all good
and Seth Rogen was there that day
because he's the EP on it and it just
that was the that was the energy sure in
that on that said it was amazing he
trusted us sure how nervous do you get
the night before a chemistry read or the
night before your meeting with some big
casting director do you sleep the night
before
it depends that one I was deathly ill
like I I was so scared I wasn't gonna be
able to make it like I was like in the
bathroom possibly going to puke right
before and somehow I made it through him
because I was sick I think I was just
like whatever John I mean drink I
couldn't get anxious about it because I
was just trying to keep myself from
vomiting everywhere but I mean sometimes
like I get less nervous now to be honest
got it yeah you just you just know that
doesn't really matters no right or wrong
you just have to trust yourself
sure completely yeah obviously and I
don't know if you aren't I don't know if
you're allowed to say but they're
filming obviously season two right now
is there any flashbacks that you get to
be involved with are you allowed to say
say I'm not in any flashbacks Oh sexy
okay got it yeah busy with other stuff
you're gonna land on your feet yeah
you're okay yeah yeah okay so let's talk
about to the Toronto Film Festival a
short film yes that is here yes no one
will have seen it who's what I mean you
know 99% of the people watching will not
have seen yeah so let's do the generic
and say what it is what it's absurd yeah
the shorts called volcano and it is
about two women who are friends
discussing relationships and one of them
is there's an abusive quality in her
relationship and it's kind of about how
how good we are at lying to ourselves
that everything's okay
and creating this facade in this
allusion to our friends to our family
that that we got it we got it going on
but really everything's falling apart
inside some I'm not mistaken the you and
the other person Hanna Hanna Cheeseman
right are your characters are called by
your real name yeah right so was that in
the script or they just said um well we
know the writer we both have a
relationship with the writer we've both
worked on shows that she's written for
okay so I think she had us in mind when
she was writing it god okay so you got a
script it was handed to you
did she say to you so you're like did
she say the character's name is
obviously you well yeah
oh yeah she's like Jess you're playing
Jess Mike how early on did you know that
this thing was coming or was it a
surprise um it was I probably knew like
a few months before but it was really
quick turnaround to it getting in tiff
we shot it in May Jesus
yeah and then she's like oh I got into
tips were like whoa okay awesome yeah
that's crazy I'm just thinking about
that that doesn't happen
no I mean I shot a feature last winter
January February that got into TIFF as
well and that was even crazier because
it was it was a full-length feature but
yeah people we should plug that as well
it's called mouthpiece it's beautiful it
opened it was one of the films I opened
the festival last year and it's part of
why I was at if rising star last year
last year anyway yeah it's beautiful
it's you can get it on iTunes now and
I've heard it is iTunes
yeah yeah yeah whole thing right right
I'm jumping and I'm already jumping into
the next thing because I said I have a
lot to go through so I absolutely love
the expanse I mean I want to stress the
word love and I can't stress that word
hard enough yeah so I heard that you
have a big role in this upcoming season
yeah so what are you allowed to say
about your role um I play my character's
name is shaundra way she is a character
in the books but she's expanded in the
TV show
I am from Earth and I am involved in an
organization that's trying to colonize a
new planet yeah I was gonna say that I
haven't read the books but yeah and I
got I saw the commenters basically come
at me for talking about things in the
upcoming season or asking questions that
are in the books right but some of us
haven't read them all
Jim so the thing but I talked to the
cast at Comic Con nice and they all said
that like the big set of this year that
say this year is the first season that
they're going outdoors yeah and it's
that planet yeah so we shot four months
yeah in a quarry that looks genuinely
like another planet right they said to
me that that's a huge like because the
last season ended in such a way that
this season is radically different yeah
so I guess
are you the antagonist yeah you could
say that there's a lot of things going
on I'm very close with some members of
the Rossi crew but I'm also yeah kind of
an enemy sure like frenemy I understand
I listen I think that that show is is so
well done what is it like coming on to
something that's a well-oiled machine
and then becoming like an integral part
of this show it was intimidating
honestly it was intimidating because I
had it was a pretty quick turnaround I'd
been doing comedy all summer got cast on
the show pretty quick and had like
wrapped some webseries and literally
four days I'm you know on this crazy set
with like a hundred background behind me
wielding a weapon happening do I
remember how to do this yeah but it was
the because the cast worked so well
together and yes this is a well-oiled
machine you trust everything that's
going on like everyone's got you sure
you know and there's such a clear vision
for the show and we always had one of
the writers on set that you yeah you
knew what what was happening when you
signed on did you know because I think
you're in like a lot of the episodes did
you know when you signed on there was
going to be so many episodes originally
addition it wasn't and then when I got
the offer yes I knew I knew that I was
gonna be in like nine yeah that's crazy
first of all congrats on booking the gig
Thanks second of all cuz I haven't seen
it yet but I cannot wait it's it
seriously that season is really really
great it's cool it's so cool yeah I'm
very gonna see some different sides of
some people I'm sure well I'm also
curious because this is the first year
that Amazon you know they say yeah and
so I'm curious what being saved by
Amazon like did that help the budget did
that like what did it do I don't know if
it reflected that much in the budget but
we know that the promo is gonna be
totally different
whereas sci-fi I'm not sure if they I
don't know how much they invested in
dollar fifty sure a roll of duct tape
exactly I think that was like the whole
issue but um Amazon as you can see with
the boys and the way that it's promote
that we I think we can anticipate like a
big yeah I think send-off yeah listen
anything I'm already excited that they
greenlit another season which is
fantastic
listen I totally want to talk more
expanse but I know that we're so guarded
on you know but so if I'm not mistaken
let's move into the next thing which is
why you got I believe its Jupiter's
legacy on Netflix yeah so I mean have
you taken a break at all in the last
year actually I have because I got a
concussion in the spring so I was off
for like four months
what did you was even like a car
accident or on a movie set it's all good
it's all good it was like nobody's
followed was a total accident I had had
a concussion before so it gets
aggravated it got bigger we did easily
but anyway yeah I was off for four
months I I was gonna go to LA didn't I
just like stayed put and so that would
that gave me a break like I had no
choice
sure that's first of all scary second of
all I'm glad you're okay yeah me too
it took a while yeah that that's like
it's hard cause it's people with brain
injuries it's like oh no it's real [ __ ]
for real okay but we've gone off on a
tangent so but Jupiter's legacy yes
health is more important than anything
but in troopers legacy that is another
if I'm not mistaken superhero show yeah
based on a comic book
totally Martin yeah absolutely you are
Mark Millar yeah I've been here yes so
talk a little bit about who you play
sure I think or yeah in this season yeah
you could say that um my character's
name is shockwave that's her her
supervillain name and she's so rad we're
in this crew of kind of misfits that um
they're criminals I don't know how much
more I can say to them I don't want to
get you enjoyed but yeah it's it's been
a blast I was just filming it this week
I'm sorry I'm filming two shows at the
same time so my question yeah this week
that's very challenging mm-hmm
but really fun so different so many
different things
what's the other thing you were filming
show go tiny pretty things yeah
oh yes that's another thing that was on
my little you know thing yeah I'm that
one's actually also based on a book
series called tiny buddy things about
some really like weird cult II messed up
ballet school and anyway my character is
that the cop that's investigating
quote-unquote crime that happened there
that is see going back and forth between
playing a villain and a cop
yeah yes it's hilarious and and last
week I had to shoot both shows in the
same day and I was like sending my
family pictures like cop and then like
this really rough like totally messy
villain and anyway it that's why I love
my job that's the stuff that makes me
love it completely when do you think
people are gonna get their first glimpse
of jupiter's legacy I think people are
saying
like fall 2020 oh wow so it's like far
away it's the biggest show that tri ever
been in Toronto like it's like it's a
big machine and there's so much if
people have read the comic books they
know that there's different time periods
and it's just a big of a series what's
it's crazy because you I keep on
thinking and I thought for years that
like you know what will it take for the
superhero genre which I love and
everyone who watches and reads Collider
huge fans of but you figure at some
point it's going to slow down but in
actuality it's still speeding up like
it's it's the most popular thing on the
planet
mmhmm yeah it's I think also what's
interesting about something like the
boys and about Jupiter's legacy is that
it kind of turns it on its head a little
bit where you see that these people have
fallibilities and they're not
necessarily to be put up on this
pedestal all the time as like the moral
compass of our culture or people that
only have pure intentions like they're
really humanized and I think that's what
the superhero genre needed it needed
something like that and you did it to be
more human but also the truth is you can
only do so much on like CW or ABC
stories you can say the fact is once you
mix in unrated you know or r-rated
there's a lot of other things you can do
and when you're willing to show blood
and guts it opens the door yeah and
that's actually what I wanted to one of
my last things on Jupiter's legacy with
the boys which really pushed does
Jupiter's legacy also push I think so
yeah I think right listen I can't wait
but I really mean it when I say congrats
on all these things you're a part of and
I really can't wait to go more in depth
once I've seen the expanse and once I've
seen some other things if you know what
I mean I'd love to chat with you when
that comes out because often times I'm
like I can't wait it was I believe it
was one of it is either our highest or
one of our highest interviews like in
terms of views
from comic-con when I had like it was
very very like way bigger than I
expected
yeah so I mean there's a huge audience
yeah you know on that note thank you so
much for stopping by and I say thanks